Carnegie Mellon University is a
top-ranked University recognized for its
world-class education in technology the
arts management and policy most
important is our unique ability to
innovate and collaborate across
disciplines Heinz college at Carnegie
Mellon University offers an academic
experience unlike any other it prepares
students with a unique ability to
conduct careful and objective analysis
of relevant data to understand and
leverage the power of information
technology and to lead and implement
change in managerial and policy context
this is made possible through the
innovative collocation of two schools
the school of information systems and
management and the School of Public
Policy and management within the college
in key areas of the global economy
thought leaders with a unique set of
skills at the intersection of policy
technology and management are in great
demand Heinz college is perfectly
positioned to develop these leaders
Heinz college is a global institution
with campuses in pittsburgh pennsylvania
washington d.c Los Angeles and Adelaide
Australia this footprint allows students
to connect and collaborate with faculty
experts at these different campuses and
to work with the counterparts and other
campuses on projects with organizations
that are part of our worldwide partner
network in Australia Africa South Asia
and North and South America
all of Hinds colleges full time masters
programs require students to complete a
capstone project solving real problems
for real clients in addition to testing
academic skills these projects also
provide practical leadership and
communication experience our annual
entrepreneurship competition made
possible through a contribution from
alumnus key block challenges students to
develop innovative solutions and
incubate startup ventures with national
and international appeal
the Heinz college community innovates in
the public private and not-for-profit
sectors and our faculty has an
impressive international reputation for
conducting cutting-edge high-quality
research at the intersection of key
policy and information technology
domains for example our faculty and
students conduct research in the areas
of criminal justice policy healthcare
information systems and policy social
and digital media and information
privacy and security our
interdisciplinary environment creates
exciting opportunities for collaboration
and produces a breadth of research work
not typically found in institutions of
our size for example the traffic 21
initiative is dedicated to advancing
research into next-generation urban
mobility problems that can be linked to
regional demonstrations and deployments
traffic 21 builds on and enhances our
leadership in urban policy critical
infrastructure and intelligent
transportation systems
the Heinz College community is diverse
in its demographic and geographic
composition as well as in the broad
range of disciplines and interests we
bring together we are unique in having
programs and students with interests in
the private the public and the
not-for-profit sectors exposing our
graduates to this variety enhances their
performance in diverse organizations and
marketplaces through an initiative we
call c-squared collaborate and connect
students interact take courses and
engage in projects with fellow students
from a wide variety of backgrounds and
degree programs our global footprint
permits these engagements across
international boundaries as well
Heins college has a strong commitment to
serving the public good through
innovation the respect to of the sector
or job our students choose they lead
positive change and inspire others to do
the same the Heinz college experience
prepares graduates for leadership on
both the global and the local scale as
well as within the public the private
and not-for-profit sectors our alumni
include elected officials at every level
of government influential policymakers
senior executives and social innovators
recent student-led innovations have
enabled creative arts programming in the
Pittsburgh cultural district launched a
start-up social enterprise that
remediate brownfields through urban
farming created a science and technology
magnet in the Pittsburgh Public School
System and produce tools and
technologies and partnership and Google
Health and the university of pittsburgh
medical center to build digital bridges
between personal health records and
hospital electronic medical record
systems invite you to learn more about
the programs faculty and student
experience at carnegie mellon
university's hines college
you